hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mother simulator now
mother simulator is supposed to be a
game that simulates all the wonderful
amazing things about being a mother
which is a very tough job and very
little reward
and apparently poop gets on the ceiling
wow that's impressive
and I don't know why there's campus in
its room but sure yeah okay alright
let's do this challenge number one meet
the baby and this test you will get
acquainted with the basics of Management
as well as our wonderful robot kid
[Music]
[Laughter]
welcome to your first test in the mother
simulator show oh it's a show during
each test you can see the brochures on
the walls these are instructions for
young mothers which detail how to
perform certain tasks directly in front
of you is one of these instructions to
approach it use walls then hover over it
and click on the left mouse button to
read it okay why is this a show oh okay
all right that's weird alright okay you
need your binky
okay got it the [ __ ] did you just say to
me kid above your baby you can see the
cloud of its desire it shows that the
child wants a pacifier what a pity that
it got dirty before you give the baby
the pacifier you should wash it go to
the kitchen where you'll find a pacifier
and a second poster with the
instructions okay baby
okay I'll be right back you don't worry
about a thing you robot apparently don't
look at me don't look at me like that oh
my god all right whoa all right
clicking the left mouse button allows
you to interact with objects and picking
them up holding the left mouse button
you can extend the hand of the object
forward take the pacifier turn on the
tap and wash it for this if it's enough
to hold the nipple under the pressure of
the water when you're done go to the
unbeatable baby robot and give him a
nipple
unbeatable men like you were supposed to
fight the baby and it couldn't lose but
I now I get it I'm not supposed to beat
the baby
all right I guess that's good enough for
me let's turn on the to extend black the
music is way too high for this okay all
right baby gift from the bit Oh No it
seems your robot kid made pee nappy by
Brad mother simulator to him now with
the taste of strawberries why why would
it why would you need the tape well be
to solve this problem do it so that he
can feel again feel dryness and comfort
[Laughter]
if the diaper with a yellow drop is
drawn in a cloud then the time to remove
the dirty diaper throw it in the waste
bag is he all right
give me that [ __ ] give me that [ __ ] kid
okay okay whoa okay oh how do I throw I
don't throw okay one two
okay throwing dirty diapers into the
basket you get a bonus points the longer
you throw it rains the more points
you'll get have thrown out and now get
go to the chest of drawers what how do I
throw it no that's not right huh uh uh
f-e are all the buttons every button
right oh there we go oh hey look at me
oh wait no we need him Robo baby does
not like to stay wet sprinkle it's
mechanical so the judge you will find
your baby take one I put it on the baby
okay wait I got a sprinkle I'm gonna
drop this I got a sprinkle
blam I missed ergo you like that baby
like that baby you want to get high all
right whatever I'm assuming that's good
enough all right there's a lot of mother
brand babies there you go oh oh you're
wonderful Robo baby is hungry when is
hunger Bopper bear in our company ultra
new tuted formula brand mother simulator
in okay in this test you're touching
robotic kid wants to try and alter
nutritious and healthy mixture from the
brand mother simulator and infant
formula trademark to cookie go to the
kitchen why is everyone cheering me you
can release the item from your hands if
you press the right mouse button to
throw the object hold it and release it
but be careful if you drop the object on
the floor it'll get dirty you need to
repair the food for the robot baby pour
this small bottle of boiling water and
add the mixture to it
only do not forget to wash the bottle
first all right
who that is that's disgusting okay give
me this extendo wash oh ah that is a
clean bottle all right drop ooh
that is a disgusting bottle alright hang
on wait how do I wait that's not what I
wanted there we go okay drop that there
okay
boil the whoa whoa hang on wait whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa all right got that
put that whoa hey there okay oh okay no
no don't sir don't throw it don't throw
it
grab that no okay scoop I'm scooping I
want to put the scoop in the doop okay
wait oh here we go to pour them in sure
in the bottle you need to put on the
table then take the box and make sure
but try not to spill the contents the
bottom can easy to turn over when you
put it not neatly when finished close
the bottle with lid and give the
evaluation of a fast Didius baby robot
if you do something wrong these little
in the bottle you have to start over
again okay let's get more water
are easy alright drop that there pick
this up click the bottle ok click did I
do it I'm assuming that's right let's
just assume you know how good things go
in you soon let me give this another
wash just in case
alright binky alright ready baby you out
here where's your diaper I don't know
what wool you better like that baby
haha what wait what binky
alright fine you get your goddamn binky
stupid baby what happens if I covered in
boiling water let's try this little
curious I'm curious just curious loop
alright baby does baby doesn't seem to
mind I guess I shouldn't mind either
hard moving
finally we're we you were discharged
from the Robo maternity hospital now you
have to look after not only your
electronic baby but also look after
yourself what does that mean well you
mean I have peed
now you also need to eat my in the upper
left corner of the screen you can see
the scale of hunger if it goes down to
zero then you will hear the signal at
the end of the test and you won't have
to start again fulfil all the way shoes
are the baby to complete the test and
welcome to your new home thank you I
guess I hate it thanks I hate it okay
alright alright thank you alright
okay baby wants a big this house is too
big Oh sausages
can I eat sausages okay eat one of those
whoa just shove them right in my god
buckets
there's the binky I guess a mother's
work never ends after all here we go
baby that's a good one all right well
okay then you little [ __ ]
alright food it is food for the baby I'm
hungry
how much food possibly need alright
three scoops I'm about to die cuz I got
no food
where's food bread perfect perfect who's
for another keep this food in my belly
numb me foodie before baby eat that's
how it go that's just the law of the
land
right this put that there clean that off
that's good I don't don't ask me how
these things got so goddamn disgusting
but they are and they did go good job
googoo gah-gah see I speak your language
- don't throw goddamnit [ __ ] baby
don't - that face your binky again god
damn it
well you know good thing I don't care
about my water bill is this just it I
got it okay all right baby oh boy all
right
no no I was not ready for this with the
baby Oh No
Oh No okay gonna put that there we go
okay I was not ready for that I was not
ready for that
where's my basket oh there it is you
peek okay all right that didn't work out
Oh
Kolby okay how am I still hungry all
right Coby damn it could all be hey I'm
hungry how give me these I guess I've
got a die cuz I've got the food what's
in my fridge oh good thank you thank you
put that away what do you want baby
again oh yeah that's right let me give
you some splash of cocaine don't look at
me like that baby here you go baby Oh
black you have the baby
pick your wolf all right I guess
breastfeed three-pointed oh wow how many
nappies your robot kid has made dirty
throw them out as quickly as possible
well the neighbors are gonna be pissed
when their windows are covered in piss
oh boy oh god how did my baby make this
my oh okay nope
all right it's got to be like it's gonna
be like skee-ball I just gotta go for
the same one consistency's the name of
the game there we go okay I got this on
lock
okay I got it apparently I didn't mean
to get it but let's try the uppers oh
wait why are those worth the same points
well that's [ __ ] Wow Wow I'm so good
I'm pretty good at this Oh gold baby
Gold baby trophy what am i ranked oh no
Papa no food poisoning oh you're poison
[Laughter]
girls what's gonna happen the baby's
poop the upper-left corner of the screen
where there's a toilet scale don't let
it overflow visit the restroom in time
well you know what I have to do I'm not
gonna visit the restroom in time all
right baby
hang on I can't jump but I'm just gonna
angle this this direction that's lovely
out there hold of though that beds nuts
are you doing back there baby well
you're about to be a lot worse
so I expected there to be an explosion
[ __ ] but I guess it didn't work out that
way okay all right all right fine I'm
the idiot then where is this God there
it is
no cover oh I gotta change your diaper -
I didn't even know that pills blast you
with powder before I [ __ ] my pants again
there you go baby that's good enough
all right good one of these bad boys
BLAP nailed it like that baby come here
baby look I'm having too much fun with
this this is too good I'm about to [ __ ]
my pants but that don't matter is your
binky boof I hope it's the last thing
because I [ __ ] my pants [ __ ] my pants I
didn't see I shat on my baby I don't
know what else you want from me up boink
nailed it I'm the best all right powder
you up laughs laughs put that away get
the speed run record on this bad boy
this is how speed runners get their
amazing tactics they they watch my video
about to blow all right you better not
want anything after that baby oh you
want food ass [ __ ] speaking of [ __ ]
speaking of [ __ ] okay there we go hey
come on it's tough being a mother and
blaming your mouth oh yeah nothing wrong
with that is there nothing wrong at all
oh yeah baby that's good well you hit
yourself in your face all right where'd
your diaper go pretty weird put your
diaper go okay what what do you mean
dirty diaper I'm about to poop my pants
huh uh well nevermind I'm good but I put
that stupid all right baby we're about
no we're not having that kind of a
conversation we're having the
conversation where I don't have to
listen to you okay that should have gone
in I have to Paul I'm gonna put the seat
down and boy though there we go that's
right yeah yeah yeah you watch you all
watch put the powder baby all right put
that down put the powder baby put that
[ __ ] that scared the [ __ ] out of me
Oh jump-scare baby holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
put that down to get this scoop scoop it
in scoop it in and I'm bout it no I'm
about to poop poop it's wasn't incoming
oh no what did you want we want for me
pretty one for me okay I don't need more
water like come on click it squash oh no
I'm not gonna make it I'm gonna make
[ __ ] this is hard hard ozone being a mom
is hard if there's one thing that I
learned it's my lesson about making
assumptions on how hard it is to be a
mother
so I nailed it got a poop
put that down sit on the nope that's not
right sit on there we go
you watch you what this is what
motherhood is all about it's not clean
it's not what it has to be done oh yeah
here you go baby here you guys a good
baby right there boy right in your face
poop incoming poop is building two
scoops just in case cuz my baby deserves
it
oh boy poop is building tremendously oh
oh I didn't flush I didn't flush that's
what I was missing I didn't flush I
should flush yeah yeah yeah
yeah whatever where's the flu sure there
it is okay I flushed in the crowd all
right and your diaper okay all right we
got this poop is building the poop river
is rising poop there you go am I done
baby
huh baby Oh got a gold baby oh oh it's
tough guys it's getting tough it's
getting real hard I had no idea ice age
every mother should be able to look
after her baby at any conditions even oh
god it's oh no oh no why come back to me
come back to me oh my god is a goddamn
slip and slide in here all right baby
here comes binky whoo boy you ready pop
it right in your gob okay there you go
what do you want is good well the poop
is building baby please oh god okay all
right here we go here we go here we go
Coby oh [ __ ] oh god what that condom
have to break oh god please
deadbeat man oh god where's your father
just please I've got so much poop
building up huh I can't oh there we go
poop is building all right put the seat
down get in the toilet all right you
shut up everybody this is reality here
oh that son of a [ __ ] I flushed No
get off it's not what I wanted flush oh
I'm gonna die my bag any bread bread
bread bread
oh sweet delectable skin in my health
that might give my hair
my mouth Oh baby no baby baby okay there
you go
put that down get that here we go and
put that on there I'm just know you take
that it okay I'm guessing you want food
next I'm just guessing
oh boy horrible food poisoning baby I've
got a problem there you go baby
okay cool okay go baby I can't go I
gotta go
bye baby ooh baby please please Mama's
gotta poop shut up everybody wants oh
god mom is angry mama don't know if mama
can't afford to flush oh god got time
just in time okay mama needs food that's
good stuff gimme gimme gimme
got no time what do you want what do you
want baby what do you want do you want
diaper change you want type II Oh No
[Music]
okay baby
here comes diaper change watch this
Kolby got that one in Hobie there we go
Kolby poof the baby okay there we go
drop that give me that
and boom it scared me again that's such
a scary baby I mean it is a robot I
don't know what hit the damn thing oh
boy [ __ ] is building poop is common Oh
food food food food for poop okay just
take this I gotta go okay I got the food
food food bread bread bread bread bread
bread
I've got poop poop oh sweet relief
sweet poopie relief oh my god how shut
up everybody you have to do this too
sometimes
okay baby what do you want what you want
baby you guys stinky how can you how can
you have that stink Oh baby
Kumi [ __ ] you Coby oh come on Coby good
golly gosh okay powder for the baby
powder for the babe oh okay put that
there grab that put that on there am I
done
nope thunder
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
baby with mountain of gifts what huh
it seems your wonderful robot kid wanted
to play with his favorite toys great
your robot kid wanted to play with his
favorite toy find a toy that he wants in
the neighbor room toys are provided by
our wonderful sponsor rattles and Doug's
campaign rattles and ducks is the
largest choice of ducks and rattles in
the world but why do I still have food
poisoning okay you want a purple rattle
well this room yes okay purple rattle
you got it okay rattle for a baby this
one sponsored by coca-cola with stars
okay excuse you you [ __ ] baby
I work really hard baby and I didn't
know that you were so intelligent that
you can tell which shapes in which
colors were there okay what else do you
want baby you're fricking freaky baby
all right we got orange with circles
orange with circles there is no orange
with circles there it is I got an orange
with circles I've only been a mother for
about 30 minutes and I'm already
extremely extremely done all right why
do I put the lid down
that's real human whatever and flush
okay all right I need food I'm back what
do you want blue duck with stars okay
Blue Duck Blue Duck it doesn't exist
there's no okay blue duck with hearts
okay sure okay all right blue duck
with hearts they're right there got it
got it yeah okay what else what else
what else baby go go baby baby I'm on a
time crunch here red with green stars
okay red green stuck got it nailed it
I'm the best I'm the best mom I'm the
best mom there you go baby just because
I'm physically repulsed by picking up my
own baby does not mean that I'm a bad
mom oh I'm a Hongo gotta give the baby
first though because I'm good mom there
you go okay take the bottle okay I got
seats which means that I'm gonna have to
poop soon after this we're Avery what do
you want Oh purple with yellow stars
okay there it is the poop the poop baby
the poop no put-downs okay we're good
down animals no not that there wow whoa
42 I'm so good at this game I'm so good
at being a mom why do I hate it so much
earthquake oh no earthquakes can cause
damage and devastation but they will not
stop a robo something falls on the baby
okay all right blue with yellow blue
with stars Blue Duck stars you got it
Blue Duck stars Blue Duck stars blue
ducks oh okay that's I bet this is the
one yeah I got it you can't stop me I
know exactly what's gonna baby I gotta
hold you when there's something going on
because otherwise this is bad all around
you know what baby I'm gonna
preemptively
okay this is bad okay what do you want
baby what do you want oh god you want
your binky I don't know where your binky
is oh there's your binky okay grab the
binky turn this on don't know why we
live in the middle of earthquakes
central there you really what do you
want baby okay green with a soy equals
whatever you you're you're not the one
you're the one no drop this one give you
down yes
okay North Craig's go getting the way of
me and my baby
boy this kid I don't even know what your
name is what's your name
[ __ ] Chucky all right what else you
want baby okay get ready for the sickest
earthquake Kobe in the world oh come on
you bounce off the rim like that no
don't throw off my aim huh
come on just get in Oh get it oh [ __ ]
you
I have to eat I'm so hungry no give me
food give me food give me food give me
food give me food I'm gonna poop I'm
gonna poop I'm gonna pop put the whip
down
get in there oh okay all right I'm on
the toilet now I didn't know that was
possible
baby what do you want oh boy oh yeah I
forgot hang on I need to get the bread
of the poopy floor Oh God why are you
out here okay powder that's important
okay baby I hate you baby
all right put you there there give me
that there's a binky in there for some
reason I don't know why so it's time to
make your Robo baby sleep wow you were
so busy that you did not notice how
night did come a child doesn't even
think of going to bed to do everything
that he needs so he can sleep peacefully
at the same time try not to doze off
first
how about some coffee all right sure
okay all right apparently I need to
sleep but thankfully might need to poop
is long gone behind me
let's read up how to make some Joe to
prepare a crisp drink you need to add a
bag of coffee to the cup and pour it
with hot water put sugar if you want so
the main question is how to drink it
just lift the cup over head and leg that
is not all right we need whoa god damn
it scary night baby
okay we gotta go gets a cup of Joel all
right so we're gonna rinse off one of
these bad boys all right let's put some
boiling water in that way first we need
to put coffee here we go oh I'm about to
pass out first okay all right that's
first priority
I go do that okay you [ __ ] baby
all right I would do this okay grab that
this is on the way so I could do this
speedrun tactics let's give this the
baby real quick real quick real quick
real quick there we go
god damn it every [ __ ] put the baby
down okay put that right there grab the
cup of coffee put that in the thing grab
that turn that on or all right poor work
who thought it work
okay blue with stars you got it baby you
got it blue with stars perfect I am the
greatest mom ever in the history of the
world what do you want baby here why
your formal Oh Oh easy peasy lemon
squeeze my nipples all right we're gonna
put you on the stove could nope okay
we're not gonna put you on the stove
okay I'm about to go to sleep and three
two one
contact Oh what the sugar doesn't do
anything for me I don't even like sugar
in my coffee hold on baby hold on coming
baby here we go there you go
diabete Oh watch this Kobus 'kiss never
mind
Kobe come on it's so close Kobe come on
Kobe whatever [ __ ] you you want to die
feat you want some pouty
you want some pouty blam okay good
enough yeah you don't get the Primo
treatment you just get the speed
treatment bring it on bring it on I'm a
good mama ooh blue with hearts oh yeah
there it is
you got it kid you got it kid I am the
best say I'm the best say I'm the best
don't throw it don't throw it don't get
sad come on come on baby
what do you want baby
okay all right how did they do badly
okay I'm getting worse at being a mom
lights out we have some technical
problems to light but you can not worry
this will not affect our shooting
process
how will it not how will it not affect
your shooting process that makes Elsa Oh
No
all right red with triangles you got a
baby I'm ready I've been training for
this my whole life
what does Ellen just read those
triangles no that is not there we go did
I get it oh okay there we go put this
down and grab that okay all right
this is fine it's probably but no put
your baby down here we go what do you
want baby what do you want you want your
binky oh yeah you want your binky oh you
know you want your binky I know you want
your binky okay all right binky in
common thank you for the baby coffee for
the mama and glog nothing like coffee
right in my eyeball excuse you what do
you want diapie okay watch this
Kobe [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
there we go seven that's what I wanted
right yeah powder fruit a baby blast
that baby put that there bring that
you're good baby on there we go I did it
baby
you know I may not be able to see you
but I feel the love that's connecting
the both of us
nice this is going in my mouth and when
did this good music get so funkalicious
at first it was like happy gameshow but
now it's just like you want to go back
to the beginning of the baby process and
make another what I'm trying to say is
this baby making music if that wasn't
readily apparent I just said it in a
really stupid way
I'm hungry baby please tell me that's
the last thing baby please oh baby oh
there we go
wow I'm getting not restart you [ __ ]
baby Oh baby I'm not even gonna [ __ ]
come here yeah
nope oh oh oh oh I'm sorry baby baby
baby oh um no one needs to see oh god
baby oh alright okay alright min never
happened no one ever saw anything we no
one had to know anything happen there
there are clothes everywhere a washing
is a part of you you know what honestly
baby I think I've had enough of you baby
you come here baby hang on wait baby
okay yeah that's uh well alright yeah
wait oops that's not maybe okay let's
just put you okay this baby and I are
we're going places all right baby you
come here oh can I put the baby in the
toilet baby no no no in the toilet okay
all right and I'm gonna take a poop I'm
sorry I didn't put the seat down I
didn't put the seat down that's what's
obviously wrong about this equation
alright this baby probably not doing so
good baby you want a bath you want a
shower shower baby
[Laughter]
what kind of extension is this on the
baby yeah baby wanna dance
OOP obey oh oh oh alright I lost the
baby okay alright then boo that's about
right so that was mother simulator what
a lovable lovable amazing poop filled
adventure still don't know where all
that poop came from in here when I tried
to poop on the baby and it didn't work
but thank you everybody so much for
watching this I hope you enjoy this a
little look into what motherhood is like
for all those wonderful
there's out there if you're a mother
yourself or you know a mother or you
have a mother well wish him all the best
because if this is a indication of what
motherhood is like then my goodness I we
don't deserve the wonderful people that
are mothers and what they go through on
a daily basis so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know if you
found down the comments below and as
always
[Music]